I recently read a post on
Humans of New York page, and
this woman mentioned in her
interview that programming is magic.
It allows us to make things with words.
Isn't that true?
So let's create our own magic.
Let's make histogram.
Firstly, let's check out
the ingredients needed
to make histogram of daily returns.
To calculate daily returns,
we need to get stock prices first.
To start with, we get stock prices for
the SPY for a period of three years.
Next step is to calculate daily return.
This is similar to what
we saw in lesson four.
Now we call this function and
pass a DataFrame to it.
We also plot the daily return value
by passing the daily return DataFrame
to our plot data_function.
This graph show the prices of
the SPY stock over three years.
And this is the daily return graph for
SPY.
Now we have our base ready,
so let's make our histogram.
And after five lessons,
you must have guessed that even
this can be done in just one line.
Here is our histogram.
Professor explained
the concept about bins.
We did not mention the number of
bins while plotting the histogram.
The default number of bins is 10.
If you look closely,
you will observe 10 sets of ranges.
Can you see this?
1, 2, 3, 4 and so on.
If you count, there would be ten.
But as usual, Python is flexible and
allows us to change the number of bins,
using the bin keyword.
We inform the histogram function that
we need to empty bins by passing
a parameter bins and
assigning it a value 20.
Now let's check our changed histogram.
Notice that the width of
each bar has reduced.
And the number of bars has increased.
If you read this graph,
it would say that
there are approximately 300
values which lie near 0.
Next we compute some statistics
on the daily return.